>>> IS IT TIME FOR THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION TO FACE AN
INVESTIGATION OF ITS OWN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S DEFENSE
LAWYER, RUDY GIULIANI, SAYS
MUELLER SHOULD BE PROBED TO SEE
IF HE HELPED DESTROY EVIDENCE
AFTER THOUSANDS OF TEXT MESSAGES
BETWEEN PETER STRZOK AND LISA
PAGE WENT MISSING.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
COMPLAINS THE POLITICALLY
EXPLOSIVE TEXT WENT MISSING DUE
TO A TECHNICAL GLITCH.
FRANCINE HATES IS A FORMER
FEDERAL PROSECUTOR AND NATIONAL
COORDINATOR FOR CHILD
EXPLOITATION AND PREVENTION.
SHE JOINS US.
FRANCINE, THERE IS KIND OF A
CREDIBILITY ISSUE HERE.
EVERYBODY IN SOME LITTLE
RINKY-DINK CIVIL COURT KNOWS
THAT YOU DON'T DO THIS KIND OF
STUFF.
HOW COME THE FBI GETS AWAY WITH
VAPORIZING IMPORTANT EVIDENCE
FROM KEY FIGURES?
>> THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION,
MARK.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THEY GET AWAY
WITH IT.
THE THING THAT CONCERNS ME THE
MOST IS THAT YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT TEXT MESSAGES THAT SHOW
BIAS.
AS I'M SURE YOU KNOW, EVERY
CRIMINAL DEFENDANT IN THE COURTS
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY ARE IN
ENTITLED TO ANY EVIDENCE THAT
SHOWS BIAS BY A WITNESS.
STRAUK WHO WOULD HAVE BEEN A
WITNESS SHOWED CLEAR BIAS IN HIS
TEXT MESSAGES WITH HIS LOVER,
PAGE.
IT WAS WRONG TO GET RID OF THESE
TEXT MESSAGES.
THEY WERE THE SUBJECT OF AN OIG
INVESTIGATION ALREADY.
IT SEEMS TO BE A CONSTITUTIONAL
VIOLATION.
>> PETER STRAUK IS THIS WEIRD
FIGURE.
HE IS ON THE HILLARY
INVESTIGATION, THE TRUMP
INVESTIGATION.
HE GETS SENT TO THE WHITE HOUSE
TO SNITCH UP MICHAEL FLYNN AND
FLOWN TO LONDON TO SEE THE
AUSTRALIAN HIGH COMMISSIONER TO
GET THE GOODS ON PAPADOPOULOS.
THEN, HE IS SENT TO THE SPECIAL
COUNCIL'S OFFICE.
ACCORDING TO THE OIG REPORT, IT
IS THE SPECIAL COUNCIL'S OFFICE
THAT REVIEWED THE CELL PHONES
AND PUT THEM BACK ON FACTORY
SETTINGS.
ISN'T THAT CORRUPTION IN THE
SPECKS COUNSEL'S OFFICE.
BOB MUELLER WAS A UNITED STATES
ATTORNEY AND FBI DIRECTOR.
HE KNOWS BETTER THAN MOST PEOPLE
WHAT IS RELEVANT TO A POTENTIAL
PROSECUTION AND WHAT IS RELEVANT
IS ALWAYS EXCULPATORY
INFORMATION.
THAT IS WHAT IS CONTAINED IN
THESE TEXT MESSAGES.
IT IS SHOCKING THAT THEY DELETED
THEM.
IT MAKES YOU WONDER WHETHER IT
WAS PURPOSEFUL.
>> THAT PHRASE YOU USE,
EXCULPATORY INFORMATION.
PROSECUTORS CAN BE PUNISHED FOR
THAT.
NOBODY SEEMS ANXIOUS TO PUNISH
BOB MUELLER.
MAYBE GIULIANI HAS A POINT.
A NEW REPORT CLAIMS THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S FORMER
ATTORNEY, MICHAEL COHEN, WHO
FAMOUSLY SAID HE HAD NEVER BEEN
TO PRAGUE MAY HAVE BEEN THERE IN
THE SUMMER OF 2016, ACCORDING TO
CELL PHONE TOWER EVIDENCE.
THAT, AS YOU KNOW, IS ONE OF THE
MOST EXPLOSIVE ALLEGATIONS IN
THE VARIOUS TRUMP -- DETAILS IN
THE TRUMP DOSSIER.
IS THIS ANYTHING REAL OR IS IT
HEARSAY UPON HEARSAY?
>> I THINK, MARK, YOU HIT UPON
IT.
I THINK IT IS HEARSAY UPON
HEARSAY.
IT REMINDS ME OF THE VERY STEELE
DOSSIER THAT WAS THE SOURCE OF
THIS INFORMATION IN THE FIRST
PLACE, THAT HAS BEEN UNVERIFIED.
IT IS STILL UNVERIFIED TO THIS
DAY.
IT RELIES UPON MYSTERIOUS
RUSSIAN OR EASTERN EUROPEAN
INTELLIGENCE SOURCES, THE SAME
THING THAT THE FBI AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ASKED THE
FISA COURT TO RELY UPON IN THE
CARTER PAGE FISA WARRANT.
IT IS NOT RELIABLE INFORMATION.
UNTIL YOU SHOW ME AMERICAN
SURVEILLANCE, BY AMERICANS THAT
PROVE HE WAS IN PRAGUE, I'M NOT
GOING TO BELIEVE IT.
>> YOU DON'T SEE WHY THIS MI-6
GUY, CHRISTOPHER STEELE, A
BRITISH SUBJECT, SHOULD BE
ALLOWED TO INTERFERE IN THE 2016
AMERICAN ELECTION, BASICALLY?
>> I REALLY DON'T.
I THINK WE SHOULD LEAVE THAT TO
AMERICANS.
>> AND PRESUMABLY, HE WOULDN'T
ACTUALLY IF COHEN HAD BEEN IN
PRAGUE, HE HAS NOW COPPED A PLEA
WITH MUELLER AND THE REST OF THE
GUYS, HE WOULD PRESUMABLY HAVE
NO INSENSITIVE NOT TO DISCLOSE
THAT.
IF HE HAD BEEN THERE, THE
INVESTIGATION WOULD KNOW IT,
WOULDN'T THEY?
>> THEY WOULD.
IN FACT, HE HAS MADE NO SECRET
OF HIS NEW-FOUND HATRED FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS EVIL
WAYS, AS I THINK HE PUT IT.
SO I THINK IF HE WAS IN PRAGUE
AND IT WAS PART OF SOME VAST
CONSPIRACY BY THE PRESIDENT TO
COLLUDE WITH RUSSIA TO THROW THE
ELECTION, I THINK HE WOULD BE ON
TWITTER TALKING ABOUT IT RIGHT
NOW.
>> YEAH, HE DOES SEEM TO BE
RELATIVELY LEAKY ABOUT THAT.
ARE WE ANYWHERE NEAR A WRAP-UP
OF THIS INVESTIGATION?
>> WELL, OF COURSE, RUMORS SAY
THAT MUELLER WILL PUT OUT A
REPORT IN FEBRUARY.
IT IS LONG OVERDUE IN MY
OPINION.
THIS INVESTIGATION HAS BEEN
GOING ON NOW FOR WELL OVER TWO
YEARS.
I QUANT IMAGIN
I QUANT CAAGIN
I QUANT CAN'IN
I QUANT CAN'TN
I QUANT CAN'T IMAGINE WHAT IT IS
THEY ARE DOING NOW.
I LOOK FORWARD TO IT.
AT THIS POINT, HE IS JUST
JUSTIFYING THE MILLIONS OF